When we were talking to Grant earlier about his future profit, he was really
interested in the maximum point on this parabola. Since this point indicated the
vertical value, the p value, of the maximum profit he could make. This maximum
point is called the vertex of the parabola, or at least it is for this parabola.
Now considering how much it mattered to Grant, and just looking at what a
special point this is on the given parabola, the vertex is clearly pretty
crucial. So let's focus on this for a second. If you have a parabola shaped like
this, opening upward, does the vertex have the maximum or minimum y value for
any point on the curve? What about for a parabola shaped like this, opening
downward?